today's show is a hard one so watch out
for the little ears
in the room and talk about issues with a
20 year old son we're going to talk
about
grieving the loss of family members who
died by suicide
we're going to talk about building
relationships with a distant stepchild
stay tuned hey what's up this is john
with the dr john deloney show
i hope you're doing well and having fun
enjoying whatever it
wherever it is you happen to be
thank you for joining us man we're gonna
talk about mental health we're gonna
talk about relationships we're gonna
talk about all kinds of stuff
man the world is an unraveling mess but
i do think there's still good people out
there and
i know there are i don't even think it i
know there are i'm looking at some out
here
there's some wonderful kind people out
here um
look at it's it's millions of people out
here by i mean
four there's four folks out there and i
think two of them are just waiting on
their uber to get here but hey thanks
for joining us man it's awesome
um if you want to be on the show i'd
love to have you i'd love to talk with
you
um give me a shout at 1-844-693-3291
that's
1-844-693-3291 or you can go to
johndaloni.com show
and fill out the form and we'll get you
on be awesome
all right so hey team kelly
james zack what i was i was
shooting i was on a shooting a tv show
this morning with somebody i was a guest
on the show and
one of the questions she asked me was
something that gets me teared up
and if you don't if you love how i'm
like humble bragging my way into this
thing that was pretty awesome right
so what is a movie that that makes you
cry
like a hundred percent time whenever you
see the scene in this movie it makes you
a tear up
um in miracle the movie about the 1980
hockey game
every time he says do you believe in
miracles even though i know we win
i'm going to cry 100 every time i i i
want to watch that movie with you just
because i don't know that it's
physiologically possible for you to cry
and so but i only cry at sports movies
for some reason
not relationship reset or death movies
just sports no
just sports and at the end of
end at the end of predator when the yeah
just the emotion of the whole the sports
and stuff i don't know why that gets to
me
james man off the top of my head the
pursuit of happiness with will smith
yeah that one especially being a father
that one wrecks me
we're gonna show it we're gonna watch
with our kids pretty soon
and they're gonna see their mom and me
weeping
have you seen it no i'm nervous you
haven't seen it it's good it's fantastic
all right zach what do you think uh that
scene in dumb and dumber when they
uh don't know that they're inviting them
onto the tour bus at the very end
you cry every time it just gets in your
heart oh yeah
sammy swamps sam said i i was way off
okay mine
is that scene in almost famous when they
get in the big fight and they're on the
bus
and they slowly just start singing the
lyrics to
tiny dancer to each other and then
pretty soon the whole bus music just
brings everybody back together
100 of the time i don't care if i'm
mowing the yard and i just got in and
i'm like hey what's up
or if i'm all pre i just start weeping
and i don't know what it is about that
i think it's just people singing along
together i love it yeah but that song
was it the whole exactly was it the
office that did the
tony danza was that from the office i
think so something else yeah i can't
hear that song now without thinking
about tony danza in america
if you're listening you just saw it
happen just then
i talking about an emotional moment and
james ruins it
so thanks james for once again
i play michael scott bringing a room
down bringing america
down but you pretty much did the same
thing to me too i was talking about what
made me emotional and then you were
making fun of it talking about predators
well yours is a borderline pathology
james is just i'm just kidding
no thank you james i do love the office
it it's good
i don't know what that has to do with
anything in this show i just want to
know what made y'all cry
what movies with movie scenes anyway all
right let's go
to mary in atlanta let's get the show
going
what's up mary how we doing i'm good how
are you
we are rocking and rolling so how's
how's everything y'all doing okay
we're doing okay we're having a few
issues that's why i'm calling you
all right so what's up how can i help
well i am part of a blended family and
my son recently moved back home
and we're having some issues how old is
he
he is 19 about to be 20. okay
and what do you move home from um
well he was just gone for a few months
he
got a job he finally got a pretty decent
job
and he went to go move in with his
girlfriend
and then he he called me one day and
asked if he could come back
home said that um that wasn't really
working out and one of his co-workers
had just rented a house and he wanted to
move in with him
it was closer to work and it sounded
good
so i was like okay but i talked it over
with my husband
and we agreed that it would be for six
weeks
and he would have to there'd be no drugs
or alcohol allowed
no girls allowed no he had to clean up
after himself and then pay a hundred
dollars a week
in rent you basically gave him the rules
that i have for my 11 year old
yeah is that a state of his i mean is
that a
signal of his emotional state as a 20
year old
pretty much because um up until he moved
out just a couple months ago he
literally was doing nothing okay so
so what's going on um so
at first he was doing really good for
like the first four weeks he was paying
his rent
cleaning up after himself clean him up
after himself he was going to work
he seemed you know to have a good
self-esteem
and then all of a sudden he started
not going to work as often as he was
and stopped cleaning up after himself
stopped paying rent
and then he called me out to talk to him
one day
and i walked out to his car with him and
he said
he started crying and said that
i didn't know him nobody knew the real
hymn that
he wasn't a good person and that nobody
understood him and i
i just i didn't know what was going on
so i told him i was like regardless of
what's
happening you know or what you've done i
still love you nothing's going to make
me not love you i said just talk to me
and he said that he's not emotionally
connected with anyone
since um his brother died and he died
four years ago in an accident he was 18.
okay and and we've been getting through
that
pretty well i thought and then you know
i was just kind of waiting for the bomb
to drop
and he said that the only one that he's
emotionally connected to
since then was my husband's
youngest daughter who is 17 and
she doesn't live with us um but he
proceeded to tell me that
they've been in a romantic relationship
and you know i i was stunned and
told him you know all the things that
could go wrong with that that
it was inappropriate and i didn't really
know what to say
but um it didn't end very well
um i tried to tell my husband which
obviously he didn't take it very well
and now over the past week
he's not they're not talking to each
other now she's mad at him because he
told us
and he's just kind of regressed back to
himself he's not talking to anybody he's
openly smoking weed in the driveway
like he's just shut down and
i you know i don't i don't know what to
do i want to help him
but at the same time i don't want it to
destroy you know the entire family
so i'm just i don't know what to do to
help him
and not destroy us so you
you cannot he's a 20 year old man okay
yes
he's got some trauma right he's got some
hard stuff
he's a 20 year old man though right
and he suffered a horrific loss of his
brother that was hard for the family
and he still should not have to having a
lease that he's got to clean up after
himself as a 20 year old
right yeah yes and so any damage that
happens to the family because you decide
to draw boundaries
are not going to be quote unquote your
fault okay
okay and you're going to have to um
unhook yourself from the other people's
choices when they run up against your
boundaries the things that you're going
to do to keep your family safe
okay okay also
you're going to love the you're going to
hold up you're into the bargain
you told him no matter what you tell me
i'm going to love you and you're going
to keep doing that
right right and that means you're going
to love him and you're going to be there
for him
and you're not going to enable him
right and he's going to have to face the
music
that if he was in a sexual relationship
with a 17 year old as a 20 year old
depending on what state he's in he just
committed a felony
and that felony was committed against a
child
and that child happens to be your the
daughter of your husband
yes right and so there's going to be
some face of the music on this deal
again you will not be the person who
destroyed your family
right right the more you hang on to that
the more you are going to enable him
to continue to hurt a child to continue
to not get the help that he desperately
desperately needs
because you're trying to own and control
the outcomes of this deal and you can't
he's got to take responsibility as a
hurting 20 year old man
right that he can't sleep with 17 year
olds he
can't smoke weed in his mom's house he
can't fill in the blank fill in the
blanks on the blank right
right so what he's got to have right now
is the
the your love and your compassion and
your accountability all wrapped up into
one
one one package real real quick because
he's really close to doing something
he can't come back from right whether
that's hurting himself whether that
is he's going to get himself in trouble
he's going to cross the line he can't
come back from
well his day to move out of our house
was supposed to be
next week and i still want to hold to
that okay
i'm nervous about it but at the same
time i feel like
if i've extended any further like you
said i'm enabling him
yeah and but i also want you to
be willing to extend an olive branch and
take him out
and say what is your plan i will help
you make a plan yeah
it's not going to be here but i'm not
abandoning you
i want to help you um why aren't you
and i don't know if you and your husband
can talk about we might help you with
counseling resources we might help you
with
um recovery resources and things like
that but it's not going to be
living here because you got a job and
he's clearly got skills
and he's also clearly got hurt right so
it's all wrapped up there together
he's gonna have to face the music with
your husband though yes
well we had initially we had planned on
taking the hundred dollars a week
rent saving that for him and then adding
400
for his birthday to give him his a
thousand dollar emergency starting fund
of course with him coming home you know
with
bags of weed i don't feel like that's
going to help him at this point
well and here's the magic the magic of
the of an emergency fund
is part the money but that's not really
it
the emergency fund is a psychological
thing
that i went bananas i
sold stuff i just ran as fast as i could
and i was able to do this
and so just handing somebody a thousand
bucks is not the same as them grinding
and grinding
it's a it's a psychological thing right
uh it would have been a great gift would
have been cool
but it would not have been effective as
him going out and grinding it out
right and earning a thousand bucks and
showing and proving to himself baby
steps i could do this
right yeah right but all that to say is
this
you and your husband have to get on the
same page today
and if not today you let him know like
hey we've got to have this conversation
tomorrow
right okay and you need your husband to
um
be as level-headed as pos as a dad of
a daughter who's been um
raped and or sexually assaulted by an
adult male can be
right which is not always very much so
and y'all gonna have to figure out
what's next steps
okay and then at some point he's gonna
have to address
your husband his stepdad at some point
you'll have to reconcile that
relationship there
and then he's gonna have to move out of
your house yes
and he's gonna have to move out of your
house with the best you can letting him
know
that you love him i would recommend i'd
say this all the time and i would tell
you the same thing too
um i would write him a letter that he
can hold in his hand
and go back to and go back to and go
back to you and i'd probably if i was
his mom make that a practice
maybe once a week it will help you
clarify your thoughts and
get all that spinning spirally stuff out
onto a piece of paper
and also it's going to give him
something to hold because someone who's
an addict someone who's suffering with
trauma
they're so so good with walls right and
defense mechanisms
they throw them up so fast as soon as
you say
you've got to move out but i love you
they're already out there listen to what
you're saying
they are into defense mode and you hate
me and you're going to ruin my life and
why don't you
fill in the blank right if they're
holding that letter they can circle back
to it and circle back to it and circle
back to it and they can read it again or
read it again and read it again
okay and even if he takes that letter
and you find it in the trash on your
his way out it's still a benefit to you
for having gotten your heart and
thoughts out on a piece of paper
okay okay but the greatest thing you can
give him right now is a plan
like a detailed plan here's where you
can go here's how
we're going to support you or not
support you here's what we expect of you
if you want to move back all those kind
of stuff
and two is your accountability your
boundaries
okay and and i'm i don't want to
sugarcoat this it may get real bad mary
yes okay yes
are you ready for that i think i am
i have gotten there i've been uh dealing
with
his boundaries for a year and a half two
years now
and i've listened a lot but i've it's
finally to that point where i think i'm
going to be able to do
what i need to do okay and
let him know he's always got your heart
and you'll always be there to meet him
for
coffee and to talk him through what's
next but that doesn't always mean he's
got access to smoke weed in your house
that doesn't always mean he's got access
to your money into your
the children in your home et cetera et
cetera right right
right okay well thank you so much i
appreciate you taking the time
no i appreciate you making the call and
i think the
the broader lesson for all of us is is a
lot of these relationships especially
when they're
young adults man drawing boundaries
sometimes for the first time especially
when you're dealing with trauma
it's not just a magic solution it gets
real real hard
oh and mary if you get a hint a
hint that he's gonna hurt himself you
call
in the calvary you call every emergency
number that you know
um if you get a hint that he's in some
sort of inappropriate relationship with
a minor you call in
everybody you call the police you call
everybody into that situation
right that's your job um
because there sounds like there was a
romantic relationship with a minor you
have to report that too
even though it's your child you're gonna
have to report that
i don't know some laws 17 is is
um of legal consent age and so depending
on the state you're in y'all can
work if y'all can figure that out with
your local authorities but um he's gonna
have a reckoning with that situation
um and that can get real messy too it
can get real messy with your marriage
and you and your husband
have to be super intentional about being
united in this deal
um man there's not always happy endings
here
i really really will be thinking about
you guys as y'all move forward
and um you and your husband want to get
a counselor to help you all unpack this
and work through this is going to be
hard
hard hard one of the most common
questions folks ask me is what they
should do when anxiety or panic strikes
like a lightning bolt
i've been helping folks 101 for years
but i wanted to create something that
everyone could use anywhere at any time
so i created a free
guided meditation it's not really a
meditation but really me just
walking with you through your anxiety
alarms from start
to finish i'll guide you through a
breathing exercise and show you how to
lean in
listen and head towards healing it is
free and it's for
everyone you can download this guided
meditation today for free at
johndaloni.com
all right let's go to leanne in salt
lake city leanne what's going on
hi uh like i'm doing good
doing good i don't get that
i don't get that like hey doing good
that makes me
makes my heart feel good no i have i
have some hard stuff to tell you but i
am blessed
and so life life is pretty good despite
oh are you a minimizer no
i like to think that i well i
okay you tell me let's do it
all right all right i feel like you're
gonna drop some heavy heavy heavy on
here
well it is pretty heavy stuff um
five years ago five and a half years ago
my husband who was 39 years old i was 34
took his life oh yeah i'm sorry
yeah hard hard things i had seven
children ages 13
and under and a four month old on my hip
at the funeral
and uh all of with was he the father of
all seven
yes yes and we have been married 15
years whoa
um so the oldest at the time was 13
and he just really struggled with his
dad's death
um it was very hard for him to overcome
we did counseling we did medication we
did treatment programs
i did everything to try to help him and
two years ago
last month he took his life and i found
him
hanging in my shed and it was terrible
and is awful but
um i am now we're two years out and
obviously still very hard but the
problem i'm running into
hey hold on real quick real quick before
you do the problem
stop there okay because you blew by that
pretty quick
that's a lot it's
it is a lot yes it's a lot
and you've got six other kids that you
immediately rallied around to take care
of
that is a lot and here's the deal
leanne i've shown up i've been in that
exact scene
holding a mother in that exact moment
right that's a lot
it's pretty horrific yeah no
mother should ever
see that ever
i agree no
no wife should
ever experience that
and i know there's some sort of
challenge that has presented itself
today
but i don't want to get to that until
you hear me say i'm so sorry
thank you i appreciate that
man
okay so fast forward three years
so your son was 16 when he passed away
18 years old
two years so it's two years ago yes he
was 16 he'd be
18 now um how was how was the graduation
was that a hard moment for you
it was when his friend started
graduating to understand that it would
be because
a lot of people don't get that oh yeah
so when his friends were graduating
yeah tonight that's a nightmare yeah and
and i want you
you're not asking for this i don't think
but as you move through
um be super intentional to
put stars on the calendar and
intentionally grieve those seasons okay
right when they start graduating his
friends graduate college when you see
their facebook stuff when you see
when the first one of his old buddies
has a kid all those moments
don't fight that just let that wash over
you
because it's gonna hurt right right
and that's that's part of the healing
and grieving process
so he dies by suicide three years ago
and then fast forward
you now you're a single mom with six
kids
yeah doing the single mom thing for five
years but now
oldest son's been gone two years so now
i have these six kids and
um you know i work a mom um
and i the struggle i'm running into
is these sweet kids it makes me
emotional i talk about it but
the hardest part is honestly just
watching my kids have to
age overnight and carry burdens that
would [ __ ]
grown grown adults and um
just watching them try to have to
weather that and navigate that
and everyone's in counseling we have we
go
we go the whole nine yards my struggle
though
and some do better than others of my
children but
it's the older ones in particular that
kind of remember their brother the most
really struggle with taking dad and
brother's death
personally that it means that i wasn't
lovable enough to keep them here and
then
maybe i'm not worthy and um you being
you being mom are you being like they're
they're feeling that individually their
voice okay
their voice feels like because i they
voice they have voices to me we're very
open and speak openly about all this
stuff
and um that has been
a worry on a lot of their hearts is if
what does this mean
that dad really didn't love me if he's
willing to just
leave and does this mean brother never
even cared about me
if he would leave us in this situation
knowing how much it hurt
having losing a family member to this
because brother knew brother went
through it too yeah
so that's the struggle is i've told them
over and over and like i said they're in
so much counseling but
they're being told this has nothing to
do with you but kids will i
just make it about them make it about if
they were
good kids or if they're not good kids
and they
i am having the hardest time correcting
that belief system that is being created
in some of them
that this was bigger than any of us that
was inside of them
and it had nothing to do with you and
still yet
especially my 16 year old daughter just
really feels like
i could have prevented this if i was a
better girl
[Music]
i hate that for you i know i keep saying
that i'm sorry that you're having to
navigate that
right um so you've if you've listened to
this show before i've talked about this
with marriages
this is one of those cases where it is
it's it's clear how it happens but kids
feel tension they absorb trauma and they
make it their fault that's the only way
they know how to regulate themselves is
with other people and when other people
die by suicide they're left looking in
the mirror with nobody
and so they look at that gap between
them and somebody that they
loved who's no longer here and they say
that what did i do
right and what a good therapist will do
is help them understand that that
illness was in somebody else's mind
right a good therapist will say it feels
like this
but here's the truth of those feelings
and
there is a part of being 16 17 18 we
gotta weather that
and it's just an uncomfortable hard
season where you're gonna really
struggle
and you're gonna have to struggle to not
project this is you're reliving this
again
because now you've got another 16 year
old absolutely
and your your brain
is gearing up for number two
right it's true it's been down this road
before
and so the challenge you're going to
have is not project what happened to
your son
statistically speaking will not happen
again
right i sure will not
there you go right it won't happen again
but you and i both know that it might
yeah right 99.99 chance that it won't
happen again
but you have lived the .001
and your brain knows that your heart
knows that so it's on full alert
as i just said kids feel that tension
and they're going to make it their fault
yes
so we've already experienced that i work
on that in therapy for myself but
inside i'm like completely
overreacting and freaking out and
outside i have to be
i'm so sorry you feel that way let's
talk about that like you know
oh hold on hold on hold on listen
i don't want to get in the middle of
your therapy right you're i'm assuming
you've got a great counselor
right but if you were my client
i'm not even licensed so i'm not going
to put that way here's what i'd
recommend to you just as a as a neighbor
okay okay when you feel
a mess inside your daughter needs to
feel that congruence
she feels that you're a mess inside and
when your face is like hey baby how's it
going
she knows there's something not right
something's not congruent there between
your
heart and your in your body and between
your heart and what you're saying to her
as one of my students who was on the
autism spectrum once said to me
i was laughing but i was also telling
him hey dude you can't have alcohol in
here and he said
your words are not matching your face i
need you to clarify for me
right it's a very similar situation so
the greatest gift you can give your
daughter
is to say i'm so scared because this is
when i lost your brother
and i love you more than life itself and
i'm scared
and then suddenly you become human and
then you become just like her
and suddenly she doesn't feel so crazy
anymore
right right does that make sense
yes and we've had those conversations
too but i i
am still i am still working through the
my son thing that
sometimes i feel like just freaking
out in a way that would scare her and so
very much i have to tone that down
that i have had those conversations that
what you're saying is scaring me so
like let's talk about that like let's
keep talking about this but
but you're right like i do i almost
probably go
to the other the pendulum kind of swings
the other way that
i don't want to i don't want to scare
her i don't upset her and
challenging after you have lost a kid
because you were holding boundaries and
trying to parent them the way that you
know they need to be parented especially
when it's a son who doesn't have a dad
and then they kill themselves
it it it is hard to stay at that level
of parenting that you know is right for
your kids to hold boundaries
and expect things of them that kids need
to be able to do
um
[Music]
your son's death was not your fault
my brain knows that my heart still
struggles
leanne i'm telling you right now your
son's death was not your fault and
you're still carrying it
yeah your son was a lovely hilarious
funny gross hairy-legged 16 year old boy
whose head was not well
right and he died not your fault
right yes
it's so scary it's the most scary it's
your heart walking outside of your body
out in the neighborhood right
right but you got to set that brick down
because when you're carrying that
gigantic cinder block of
somewhere deep down i i i'm responsible
for this all
that brick is taking up both of your
hands and you can't fully grab
and hug the life into your other kids
with all your might right right
yeah and so your grief to quote the the
grief
the greatest grief guy on planet earth
david kessler your grief has to be
witnessed
someone's got to sit in it with you and
there is no better people on earth to
sit in it with you than those who
experienced it with you
right right have you all done those
exercise
exercises where you all um especially
you and your
your 16 year old we all write them a
letter together
no we haven't i'd recommend that and
maybe ask your therapist to do that
um do y'all want to do that together all
three of you
but y'all write him a letter and or you
write one and she write one and you'll
read them
out loud in a counseling session
and in that letter you talk about how
much you miss him how mad at him you are
how much you love him and then the
beautiful the beautiful part of this
is you're both seeing you're both
letting your feelings that are on the
inside come be seen on the outside and
then
you talk about who you're going to be
here's the kind of mom i'm going to be
here's how we're going to make meaning
of this mess
and what that begins to do for you for
you and your 16 year old is it begins to
plot a course for tomorrow
and when those that we love die by
suicide our tomorrow just goes away
right you just stumble through every
single day to get to the next day to get
to the next day
my guess is you've already mapped out
just like probably to the day
how many days you got left with all six
of these kids right
it is just how i can get through today
get to today get today get to today
and it's hard and it's hard and it's
hard and once you turn want that for
them
i know i'm not the mom in survival mode
leanne lyan i don't want this for you
you're too extraordinary you're too
extraordinary
and right now you are living a life that
you've got duct taped and knitted and
nailed together because you're trying to
hold it together for them
and you've got to exhale and let that
thing go
and that means you have to let your son
go and you're still holding on to him
because you still want to edit the story
because somehow you think you're the
author of what happened and you're not
okay and there's nothing on this call i
mean
like what has happened to you should not
happen i'm so so sorry
thank you and what i want for you is to
feel that i want your kids to feel that
their mom feels
i want their kids to know my mom's human
and that she is a mess just like we are
and that we miss miss our brother miss
miss dad that we super are mad at them
and we understand what they did and we
don't understand it but we understand
that they weren't
they weren't well all right then we're
going to start short
charting of course for tomorrow we're
going to make mean of this stuff
and what a gift your gift is not going
to be making sure they don't get any
bumps or bruises your gift is going to
be
letting them see your bumps and bruises
yeah let them see your scars that's the
gift you give them at this point
and letting them know they're the most
precious special wonderful messes on
planet earth
right okay
i can do that i will do that but that
starts with you
letting this putting that brick down
yeah and that sounds a lot cooler yeah
super meg like it's a cool thing to see
on the radio and then just like
click over the next call and you hang up
and you're like well i don't even do
that
start with a letter okay right
start with a letter talk to him about
that you're so sad that you're missing
graduation and it's also awesome to see
his buddies graduating
and you are pissed that he's not
graduating
maybe send his buddies a card
and congratulate them that's the that's
the little breadcrumbs towards making
meaning of this
doesn't you cheer on his classmates
right when you call his old girlfriend
and you
send her a note to say hey don't call
her because that could be kind of weird
but
um to send you a little card or
something says we miss you and
happy graduation whatever i don't know
what the what the story was there but
right um begin the slow the slow turn
into making meeting this thing
but i check on that start there with a
letter start there with your daughter
writing a letter
you doing it and i think reading out
loud to each other is going to humanize
you in front of your daughter
and remember this she's watching you
for her only picture of how
a strong wonderful mother a strong
wonderful woman deals with hurt
right and you want her to be able to
feel this to acknowledge it to own it to
to stumble and and cry and get dragged
down that river
of grief you want her to experience all
those things
but you got to show her you got to model
it okay and that's how you end up
becoming well too
thank you so so much for your call ian
you're a brave wonderful woman
if you if you would be willing to it's
it'd be a brave thing but after you read
your letters to each other
um again preferably with your counselor
if y'all read your letters to each other
i'd love for you to give me a call back
and let me know how that went i'd love
to know
um about how that moment was between you
and your daughter i think that's gonna
be a remarkable remarkable turn for your
family
thank you so much for the call all right
let's take one more call let's go to
zach
in huntsville alabama zach what's going
on brother
uh no huntsville texas is not hunting
that's cool
huntsville texas huntsville texas yeah
right right down the road from where i
grew up
what's up man uh not much
chilling on the way to deliver a load of
drive a truck for a living
but anyway so colin because uh my wife
has a daughter from a previous marriage
so technically my stepdaughter and uh
we've been talking about trying to get
custody back we tried a few years ago
when she was three
it didn't work out uh why did your wife
got herself
lose custody um
it was a mixture of voluntary and then
just uh
uh like uh i'm gonna go back to the
beginning of the story to try and keep
my thoughts on track
otherwise i'm gonna get sidetracked um
well i mean it's just
did she have a did she have an addiction
problem was her abuse in the home
oh no nothing like that um she just
signed over voluntary
custody of her child uh the okay uh her
dad
uh
okay her former mother-in-law
started watching her when she was about
a year and a half
it was just before my wife and i got
together
and she asked my wife to sign papers
given her temporary temporary custody
just for legal purposes um
on the paper in colorado where uh cassie
lives
uh the paper asks for a thing
it's got a section that asks you for how
many hours the parents are going to
visit the child
and her former mother-in-law put five
hours
just to start with claiming it was legal
purposes but that she'd have access to
the kid no matter what
and then following that she started
following those five hours religiously
like it was five hours a week no more no
less for
pretty much the whole time my wife were
together and i were together until we
got married
so basically what you're saying is hold
on so what you're saying is
you're stepdaughter's
grandmother yeah
falsified documents tricked the mother
of
her granddaughter into signing papers
that she didn't fully get
that signed custody away of her daughter
limiting to
five hours a week where a mom could see
her baby
yes and no uh her following the the
five hours religiously was part of it
but the documents were all legal and
everything like that that's not where
we lost custody uh flash forward
about uh flash forward about five months
later
uh my wife and i we got married we i've
been driving truck the whole time so we
hadn't really gotten like proper
honeymoons or anything
so we decided well why don't you come on
the truck with me we'll go out for just
a little over a month we'll go to
galveston
and see my father-in-law because he
lives down in galveston
and then we'll come back brett before
christmas and then we talked to her
mother-in-law
and asked if cassie could continue the
visit because he's the daughter of his
name
but um asked if we could continue the
visits with
my mother-in-law and sister-in-law who
we were living with at the time
so that we could skype her and see her
and so that the visits wouldn't
keep the routine going two weeks later
when
my wife's grandma asked for a visit she
just paraphrasing the message mother uh
former mother-in-law sent the message
back saying i'm not obligated to get the
family visits they're not continuing
till
colleen gets back so we called her we
were like all right we're
filing for full custody we're going to
court
flash forward another seven months i
want to say because her and her attorney
kept pushing it forward and forward
finally around august we said all right
enough's enough but
in the couple month two months leading
up to that
everything fell apart for us my my
mother-in-law my wife's mother
relapsed on drugs she trashed the house
for
a a considerable amount of time while
she was living with us
and then at the custody hold on
hold on hold on this is like turn into
jerry springer brother like
let's let's let's reign this all the way
back in okay
no it's all good it's all good your
story is your story man i'm uh
it sounds like a mess okay
here's a mess and then some yes
so where i'm not tracking with you
is this
um i got a five-year-old little girl
you'd have to come through hell and back
to make it to where i couldn't see my
daughter
like i'm talking you have to shut down
the city of nashville to keep me out of
seeing my daughter and so
something here isn't doesn't pass my
smell test there's something
weird going on here that why a mother
would sign over custody or some sort of
five hour rule or some sort of hey thing
and
i'm just gonna take off for a month and
i'll just skype in with my daughter
none of that sounds right so i don't
know the picture
i don't know the particulars of it and
we don't have time on this show to go
all the way back into it i just want you
to know that
there's something about that that
doesn't and i'm not super dad either
dude
i'm just a regular guy like something
there sounds
screwy but fast forward to now now y'all
are circling back
and you want to regain custody
and how old is this little girl she is
seven currently and
just a brief little context
a judge turned the temporary custody
thing into full custody when we went to
court
and over the last few years i'm not
gonna lie we have not been perfect
parents or
anything close to that we have had very
limited visitation and then trying to
circle back to
but listen a judge a judge only does
that a judge
only does that when they're like a judge
man i've been through so many situations
and walked alongside people who
i could not believe the judge gave them
back to their biological parents
but every judge i've ever seen their
bent is how do i get these families
reunited
so there was something there that the
judge looked at either your current wife
or that current situation and said nope
and i just can tell you my experience
has been there's something extreme there
there's something
really challenging going on in that home
for them not
for you've got a mother saying dude i
just want to be in my kid's life
that's the dream of every court i've
ever seen now i know every court's
perfect and there's idiots ever i get
that
but so now here you are seven seven
years later
and you're asking how do you loot how do
you
reinsert yourself into this daughter's
life
is that is that the ultimately when we
distill down is that the question
um yes and no we haven't necessarily
left her life
but she's growing up we're trying to
reconnect with her
in a proper way and see if custody can
be an option a few years down the road
we're not trying to go for immediate or
anything like that we know that's not
good for her but okay
okay and is the custody for
the her best interest or is it because
you all miss your daughter and you want
to
start seeing her some more like why why
now
it's a little bit of both like we will
admit we've discussed it and if we
decide that
if going down this road we decide it's
in best interest for her to stay with
her
uh grandmother we will definitely make
that call
because we
we've never been fully out of her life
or anything like that we have regular
contact with her and everything like
that
um but hey i want you to hear how that
sounds to me
okay this is her mom
like my wife doesn't like to leave my
daughter like with the neighbor
for a few hours do you hear what i'm
saying
i don't feel like i don't feel like i'm
being super clear
um i get you you're working hard you're
a step dad
you are like in in life you were doing
the couple hours saying i get that
but your wife is this little girl's mom
does that make sense um is that register
yeah um so like are you wondering like
what my wife is struggling with
no no no no no i don't think that's a
whole that's a whole other show we can
that's a whole other call right um
he ultimately here's what y'all are
gonna have to do you're gonna have to go
to court
or you're gonna have to get with a
lawyer or go see a judge and you're
gonna have to ask for an
avenue back
and there's been some sort of behaviors
whether that's
addiction whether that's abandonment
whether it's neglect whether that's
just there's something there that
a court that is designed to reunify
families has said we're not doing that
in here and i've never experienced it
where there's not a series of
services there's not a plan that a mom
and or a dad can work to reintroduce
themselves into the life of their child
i've never seen that it may exist in
your situation i've never seen it
unless parental rights are terminated
you're out
right you all aren't in that case
because you'll still get a few hours a
week or a month or whatever
but what i'm doing if i'm you the first
thing i'm doing
is i'm gonna go get a lawyer i'm gonna
get a judge i'm gonna ask them what is
i want to be in the life of this girl
and i think you and i could talk for
probably two hours or five hours
and i'd hear all kinds of stuff in the
story
and there's probably blame to cast
everybody mess to cast over i get that
but it's going to come back with you
looking at illegal somebody who
has taken away most of your custody if
not all of it
and saying i i'm gonna do whatever it
takes whatever
it takes to let that little girl know
that i love her more than life itself
and that i've made some mistakes i
haven't been to use your words not
haven't been perfect
whatever that means um i'm gonna do
whatever it takes
and then you're gonna have to give
someone to give you a plan and you're
gonna have to exceed that plan
you're gonna have to go to all the
classes they tell you and you're gonna
take extra classes
you're going to send a letter a week
you're gonna write letters let this
little girl know how much she's loved
and not so much you but her mother is
going to write letters
right and you're going to um
when you say you're going to show up
you're going to show up you're going to
be early and you're going to drop off on
time
you're going to be respectful and
dignified of her living arrangement
you're going to show up at all the
school meetings you're going to show up
you're going to show up you're going to
show up
and if you live in different towns like
we just can't do that right now
then this may not be the season for you
because you're going to have to convince
a judge
or a group of lawyers you have to
convince a judge
are you all screwed up and you're ready
to be make it whole
and i i can't wrap my
this is your daughter
everything in the world comes after that
everything everything
your wife's work your wife's plans your
wife's dating life your why
everything comes after that one thing
that's her little girl
and i'll burn it all down because i love
my daughter that much
so that's where you start start with a
judge start with a lawyer and say what's
my plan back
and you all work that plan you exceed
that plan but not just to get custody
you don't get close
no no you got a lot of healing for that
little girl
and you want that little girl to grow up
in a better situation than she
you want her kids to grow up in a better
situation than she did
and she's gonna have to know that her
mom values her
and that starts with a lot of
generational healing there man
all right thanks for that call man all
right as we wrap up today's show
let's just circle back let's go full
circle i hadn't really planned to do
this but
let's just do it we're going to be
cheese ball deluxe today
1971 release on the madman across the
water album
the one and only mr elton john
sings tiny dancer and it goes like this
blue jean baby l.a lady seamstress for
the band
pretty eyed pirate smile you'll marry a
music man
ballerina you must have seen her dancing
in the sand and now she's
in me always with me tiny dancer in my
hand
jesus freaks out in the street handing
out tickets for god and turning back
she just laughs the boulevard's not that
bad
i was hoping you guys were gonna join in
and sing along with me we're gonna have
like a moment on the bus this is a hard
show man
you guys are letting the team gotta
start singing you gotta lead piano man
nope he makes a standard auditorium
looking on she sings the songs the words
she knows the tune she hums
but oh how it feels so real lying there
with no one near
only you and you can hear me when i say
softly slowly
hold me closer tiny dancer
count the headlights on the highway lay
me down in sheets of linen you had a
busy day today
this is the dr john dolone show
[Music]
you